JANICE KAPLAN: Thank you.
Thank you all for being here.
I know you're all busy, and
I appreciate your being here.
And it's exciting to get to
talk to you about gratitude
because you're all at Google, so
you are all grateful every day.
Because the rest of
us who are not at
Google know that you work in the
best place in the entire world.
You get free food.
I took some on my way in.
You get free coffee and tea.
You get everything, right?
And so when you
go home at night,
and maybe something didn't go
quite as perfectly that day
as you had hoped, maybe
somebody annoyed you, or maybe
something didn't work
out right, and you
tell your boyfriend or
girlfriend, or husband or wife,
or mother or father, or whatever
stage of life you're at.
You complain to
somebody, and they
say, oh, for heaven's
sakes, you work at Google.
I don't want to hear it.
You're lucky.
Realize how lucky you are.
So most of us are
pretty lucky, right?
And we know that we should
feel grateful all the time.
But we don't.
And let's just admit it.
We don't.
And I know how you feel-- if
there are those days that you
go home, and you're not
feeling so grateful,
and everybody's telling
you that you should--
because it's how I felt too.
As that nice introduction
said, I've had a great career.
I was the editor-in-chief
of "Parade,"
which was, at the time, the
biggest magazine in America.
I've been a TV producer.
I've had lots of
fun things to do.
I have a lovely husband.
I have two great kids.
But for me, it started
on a New Year's Eve.
And I was standing at a
party at a New Year's Eve.
And I don't know how you
guys feel on New Year's Eve
or how you felt on this
past New Year's Eve,
but I'm always pretty
sure on New Year's Eve
that everybody in the world is
having a better time than I am.
And we turned on the TV at this
party, and the ball in New York
was about to fall,
and I'm sure you
have the same experience with
whatever falls, or screams,
or goes up in smoke in London.
And I stood there, and
I thought, OK, it's
been a perfectly nice year.
There's nothing bad
that's happened this year.
I knew I had a
perfectly nice life.
But what was going to happen in
the coming year that was really
going to excite me?
What was going to happen
in the coming year
so that I could be standing at
that same New Year's Eve a year
from now and thinking, wow,
what a fabulous year this was.
And I went through
various things in my head,
and I realized, well,
I probably wasn't
going to win the lottery.
But if I did win
the lottery, I'd
probably complain that
the taxes were too high.
I probably wasn't going to
move to Hawaii, but if I did,
I'd probably get a sunburn
and be unhappy about that.
And basically, I
realized that whatever
happens in the course
of a year, it's
really not the
events that happen
that make you happy
or unhappy, but it's
your own attitude towards them.
And so that's when I decided to
challenge myself for the coming
year to see if I could spend
a year living more gratefully
and see if that would
really make a difference.
Now, if it sounds like I was
incredibly smart on that New
Year's Eve to know that it's
not events that make you happy,
it's your attitude
towards them, I
had actually been working on
gratitude for a year or so.
I had been asked by the John
Templeton Foundation, which
is a big, wonderful,
international foundation, to do
a survey for them on gratitude.
And I had done it.
It was just a project for them.
But then the results
started coming in,
and they were really,
really interesting.
Where something like,
if you ask people,
does gratitude make you happier?
Are grateful people happier?
Something like 90% of
people say absolutely,
gratitude makes you happier.
And if you say, are you grateful
for your family and friends?
They say, sure.
Again, 85%, 90%
say, of course, I'm
grateful for my
family and friends.
And then you say, do
you express gratitude?
And then the number plunges.
And then all of a sudden,
it's at, like, 40%.
So I started calling
that the gratitude gap.
And I'm a journalist.
I went on TV.
I was talking about it.
I wrote articles about it.
And it took till that
New Year's Eve though,
for me to realize that I was
as guilty of that gratitude gap
as anybody else.
And what I mean by
that gratitude gap
is that we know
there's something
that's going to make us
happier, but we don't do it.
And what's holding us back?
Why don't we?
I think there are
lots of reasons,
and we'll get to some of those.
What I found in the
course of that year,
let me just jump ahead
to the end of the year,
is that by being grateful, by
trying to turn things around
on a daily basis,
by trying to find
the positive in
any kind of event,
I ended up, oddly enough,
with the best year of my life.
And nothing special
happened that year.
I can't tell you
any fabulous event
that happened in that year other
than that I wrote that book.
And yet, it was such
a wonderful year.
And it was because my
attitude towards things
made me so much happier.
And I think that
that's what I'd like
to be able to share
with you is the ways
that you can start
to feel happier
by using gratitude in that way.
So in the course of the year,
I dealt with relationships.
I dealt with family.
I dealt with all
sorts of things.
But one of the things that
I dealt with was work.
And since we're
all here at Google,
and I know you all
work, I just thought
we could talk about gratitude
at work for a couple of minutes.
And I think gratitude at
work has two sides to it.
One is appreciating
the job that you have,
and the other is being
appreciated at your job.
So let's start with the first
one, which is appreciating
the job that you have.
So all of you
remember, probably,
when you applied for
this job, and then
how thrilled you were
when you got it, right?
You got the job at Google.
That was really great.
And now, it's the
job that you have.
So you probably don't wake
up every single morning,
grateful for the fact
that you have this job.
Psychologists call
it habituation, which
means you get used to stuff.
You want something,
and you want it.
You want this job.
You want a diamond ring.
You want a Porsche.
You want something.
And then you get
it, and it becomes
the background of your life.
It just becomes the baseline.
And once we're at
the baseline, what
do we want except
the next step, right?
So we stop noticing
where we are.
We stop noticing what
we actually have.
And that's true,
frankly, with a job.
It's true with a
spouse, with a partner,
with all sorts of things.
And at one point, I was
calling it the Porsche
in the garage syndrome.
Because I know so
many people who
are desperate for a Porsche.
And they just think it's
going to change their life.
They're going to be so happy.
And then they get the Porsche.
And that first day, they're
driving through Los Angeles.
And they're so excited.
And they're showing it off.
And then after a while,
the traffic is still lousy.
And they got to change the oil.
And it's just the car they
drive to work every day.
So that becomes the
Porsche in the garage.
And who's excited about the car
that they have in the garage?
So what do you do at that point?
Well, I guess you could
get a Lamborghini.
You work at Google, maybe
you could get a Lamborghini.
But you get the point, that
you can always up the ante.
You can always try
to up the ante.
But probably what's going to
happen is you up the ante,
and you end up feeling the
same as when you started.
So if you realize that, that's
the point at which you go, OK,
so how do I stop and appreciate
where I am right now?
And again, I ask the question
before, why don't we do that?
And I think at work, one
of the reasons we don't
do that-- excuse
me-- is that we're
afraid that if we're
grateful for what we have,
we're not going to get any more.
We have this image that
you have to be miserable.
You have to be a
little unhappy where
you are in order to want
to get to the next step.
That somehow, we have
this sense of ambition
as being something
that means-- I'm just
going to grab that water-- that
means that I can't be satisfied
where I am right now.
I have to keep wanting to
go on to something else.
Well, one of the
things I discovered
is that gratitude
and ambition actually
play very nicely together.
That when you're grateful
for what you have,
when you appreciate what
you have, you're happier.
You're a lot more
fun to be around.
People like to be with
positive people, right?
And you're much more likely to
be able to take that next step.
And because you feel
good about yourself,
you're much more likely to be
able to take that next step.
So I think that's so important
to realize that gratitude
isn't a pat on the back.
And gratitude isn't
just a platitude.
I'm from New York.
I am neither soft nor sappy.
And I knew that gratitude
feels really soft and sappy
to a lot of people.
But I knew that if, at
the end of the year,
it was just that
pat on the back,
it was just my saying
to myself or to others,
oh, yeah, yeah, yeah,
everything was fine,
that wasn't going to be right.
But much more
important is that we're
able to spin our
own lives, right?
We're able to spin
how something happens,
to look at the bright
side of it or to look
at the negative side of it.
And we tend to be really good
at looking at the negative side.
So if 10 good things
happen to you in a day,
and one bad thing
happens, what's
the one you remember when
you go home at night?
What's the one you tell your
significant other about over
dinner?
You're unlikely to go through
the nine fabulous things that
happened, but you're
probably going
to focus on the one negative
thing that happened.
Now, again, there's
a reason for this.
Some psychologists say
that it may be hardwired,
that we may be hardwired
to focus on the negative,
and for a really good reason.
That our ancestors
in the jungles,
they were picking berries.
They really needed to know
which was the poisonous berry.
Knowing which were the nine
tasty berries didn't matter
that much, but knowing which
was the one poisonous berry
was really important,
otherwise, they
did not become our ancestors.
So we've moved
beyond that though.
And yeah, it's important to know
where the poisonous berry is.
It's important to know
where the problems are
because you want to be able
to do something about it.
But just focusing
on those and not
knowing where the
nine tasty berries are
is probably not the best way
to have a happy life either.
So how do you do that?
What are some of the
specifics that you can
do to make yourself appreciate?
Well, one of the
women that I spoke to
as I was writing the book runs
a very large profit in the US.
And she has a couple of kids.
And she was, as many of you
are, overwhelmed by work,
and busy at home, and never
felt like she was doing enough
for anybody.
And she told me that she
came up with a solution.
She had a 20-minute drive home.
And that she decided
that for those 20 minutes
in the car on the
way home every day,
she was only going to go
over the good things that
had happened that day.
She was only going
to let herself
think about the positive
things, the nice thing
that somebody had
said, the success
that she'd had at work, the
achievement that she'd had.
And she wasn't going to
think about the problems.
Now, there are problems at work.
We have problems at work.
Thinking about the positive
doesn't make them go away.
It doesn't mean they
don't exist anymore.
It doesn't mean you're not going
to have to still solve them
the next day.
And I think that's the other
thing that we forget about.
We think, if I'm obsessing about
it, it's going to get better.
It's not going to get
better if there's nothing
you can do about it that night.
So thinking about
the positive things
is possibly going to put you
in a better frame of mind
in order to be able to
do better the next day.
Another simple thing
that you can do.
People talk about keeping
a gratitude journal.
That sounds kind
of onerous, right?
We all work really hard.
You write.
You're on your computer all day.
Do you really want to have
to go home at night and keep
a gratitude journal?
I think of it as keeping
a little piece of paper
next to your bed where
you scrawl down one thing.
Scrawl down one thing
before you go to bed
at night that is about something
good that happened that day.
And I know it sounds
really simple,
and it sounds really small,
but you would be so surprised
how knowing that
you're going to do that
changes your entire day.
So give yourself a week.
Tell yourself you're
going to do it for a week.
Who can't do
something for a week?
And you're going to
wake up in the morning,
and you'll have
your cup of coffee,
and you'll go, oh, grateful for
my cup of coffee, that's it.
I don't have to worry about
this for the rest of the day,
I've got what I'm
going to write about.
OK, that's fine.
You've also put
yourself in a little bit
of a positive framework at
9 o'clock in the morning,
and that's not a bad thing.
Or maybe it gets to be 4
o'clock in the afternoon,
and you go, oh, gosh, I haven't
been grateful for anything
today, and I'm going to have to
come up with something tonight.
What should I be grateful for?
And maybe you go, you know what?
I'm going to be grateful
for that piece of chocolate
that I have right
here, because why not?
And I'm actually going
to stop and appreciate
this piece of chocolate,
and appreciate
that it's really tasty,
and that it was out there,
and that that's
kind of a cool thing
that I have this
piece of chocolate.
And I'm going to appreciate it
in a slightly different way.
Or maybe you just look out.
And the sun is down now,
but when I walked in here,
the sun was just absolutely
beautiful on the buildings
across the way.
And maybe you see it every
day, but maybe you actually
pause and think, I'm
going to be grateful
today that I get to see this
beautiful, beautiful sight.
And again, it's
such a small thing.
It's not interfering
with your day very much.
with your job very much.
But it's putting you in a
slightly different frame
of mind.
It's such a small thing that
you can do for yourself.
And as you start to
do it more and more,
you'll find how simple
it is to actually do
in circumstances that are
difficult or frustrating.
I flew in from New
York the other night.
It was a great flight.
We got in.
I got to customs or
passport control,
and there was an hour
and a half line there.
There was really nothing
I could do about that.
I said to my husband, do you
think I could have a fit,
and they would put
me through first?
He said, no, I think they
would put you in jail.
So we're standing in line,
and 30 minutes goes by.
And you're tired at that point,
and you're a little bit grumpy.
And I thought, no, I don't
want to start my trip here
being grumpy.
I'm excited to be in London.
So I said to my husband,
let's play the gratitude game.
He's done this enough now.
He goes, all right, Ms.
Gratitude, go ahead.
And I said, I'm so excited
that we're in London.
This is really cool.
I'm so happy.
I'm so happy that I'm going
to get to talk at Google.
And it became a joke, of course.
But it made us
laugh, and it made us
both say, what's the big deal?
We're standing in
line, you know?
OK.
And there's nothing
we can do about it.
Now that's the other
thing about gratitude.
If there's something you can
do about the situation, do it.
Gratitude is not meant
to turn you into a sap.
Do anything that you can.
But so often in life,
we're in situations where
we can't do something about it.
And all we can do, all we can
control, is our attitudes.
What's surprising,
I think, also,
about being grateful, about
knowing that you can do that,
is how it gives you a bit of
control back in your life.
Because sometimes, when
you're in a situation
like you're standing in line,
or you're caught in traffic,
or the tube is late, or
whatever the problem is,
you just feel helpless.
And that's part of
the frustration.
There's nothing you can do.
You just feel helpless about it.
And if you allow yourself
that gratitude moment,
if you allow yourself
to say, I don't have
to make this
irritating, I don't have
to have this something
that frustrates me,
it gives you a bit
of control back.
And that has a really, really
surprising effect on you.
So I said at the
beginning that there are
two sides to gratitude at work.
One is appreciating
your job, and the other
is being appreciated.
And as I was doing the book,
and as I was talking to people,
I was stunned by how bad we are
at expressing thanks at work,
or having people say
thank you to us at work.
And it's such a surprise because
every "Harvard Business Review"
article now, every
book, every psychologist
who writes about this
subject, talks about the fact
that most of us are
motivated-- of course,
we want to have a good
paycheck, that's the baseline.
We understand that.
But most of us are
really motivated
by feeling that the
work we do is important,
and feeling that the
work we do matters,
feeling that we're
doing something
that people will appreciate.
And as I was writing
this book, and I
was talking to executives,
one after another
would tell me, no, no,
no, we say thank you here
with a paycheck.
And it's an old line that
people have been using.
If you know the
TV show "Mad Men,"
they use that line in the '60s.
And I finally got
to the point where
I wanted to say, no, you don't
say thank you with a paycheck.
You say thank you
with thank you.
You say we're paying
you with a paycheck.
And I know at Google, and I even
mentioned Google in the book,
one of the mantras
from the HR people
is we appreciate the
people who work here,
and we want people to be happy.
And that's great.
And I hope that that corporate
ethos does indeed exist,
and that you do feel it.
But everybody's an individual.
And there are
probably some of you
who have people
who you report to
or who you deal with who
aren't quite as good at that,
and who have high expectations,
and who have the feeling
that, if I have
high expectations,
you'll work harder.
They're wrong.
That survey that I
did for the book,
we found that 81% of people
said that they would work harder
for a grateful boss.
And 90% of people said that they
thought a grateful boss would
be more successful
because people
would rally around him or her.
And really, nobody
succeeds, nobody
gets to the top on their own.
So those are two really,
really important numbers to me.
That people will work harder.
If you're the boss, if there
are people who work for you
or report to you,
people will work harder
if you say thank you to them.
And you're more likely
to be successful.
So once we realize that, there's
pretty much no reason at all
that we wouldn't be grateful.
And I had the experience.
I was in New York a
couple of months ago,
and I was having dinner
with a friend of mine
who is a partner at a big,
big New York law firm.
And he made a call
during dinner.
And he was obviously
speaking to an associate.
And he said to him, I need that
on my desk tomorrow morning
at 8 o'clock.
And he hung up.
And I said to my
friend, does that
mean that guy's going to
have to work all night?
And he said, yeah.
And I said, well, are you going
to say thank you to him when
you go in tomorrow morning?
And he said, no, it's his job.
Now, I'd written a
book on gratitude, OK?
He knew it.
And I said, OK, here's an idea.
Why don't you stop on
your way into the office,
and buy a cup of coffee,
and put it on his desk.
And say, I appreciate that
you had to work all night.
You don't even have
to say thank you.
Just say, I appreciate that
you had to work all night.
And my friend got
it, and he laughed.
And he said, yeah, the
coffee's a good idea
because at least he'll stay
up for the rest of the day.
So sometimes, it really
is those small things,
those small things
that remind us
that we're in an
environment where
we need to support each other.
And there's a CEO.
Actually, he was the
CEO of Campbell's Soup.
His name is Doug Conant.
And he was the CEO there
from 2001 for 10 years.
So probably, he left
a few years ago.
And when Doug got to
Campbell's, the company
was not doing that well.
It's a Fortune 500 company
in the United States,
but it was not-- you know
what Campbell's is, right?
They make soups.
It's international, isn't it?
And it was not doing well.
And Doug's job was to come
in and turn it around.
Now, he's a really
smart businessman.
And I'm not taking away any of
the business side of things,
which I completely
don't understand,
but I'm sure he did brilliantly.
But he also told me
that one of the things
he did there was that
every single day,
he wrote six handwritten
thank you notes
to somebody in the company.
And it wasn't just to the
executives who worked for him.
He would send it off to somebody
in a plant in some small town,
or to the guy who's on the
assembly line somewhere,
or to the guys who
were packing the boxes.
And he actually had
somebody on his staff
whose whole job
was to find things
that people had done
good in the company
so that he could send
them the thank you notes.
And you could multiply it out.
I didn't, but he
told me writing six
thank you notes six days
a week for 10 years,
he figures he wrote about
30,000 thank you notes.
And the twist on that story
is that one of the last years
that he was at the company, he
was in a terrible, terrible car
accident.
And he was in the ICU,
the emergency unit,
for a couple of weeks.
And they actually weren't sure
that he was going to survive.
And he started getting notes
in from around the world.
And his wife was
sitting on his bedside
and reading him the notes.
And as you can imagine,
so many of them
were from people who
worked for him, from people
who were writing to him and
saying, you don't know me,
but six years ago, you
sent me a thank you note.
And my family was so proud, and
it's been on our refrigerator
ever since.
And so I've always felt like
you're a member of the family.
And now, my thoughts and
prayers are with you,
and I hope you get well.
And Doug was so
incredibly moved by that.
And he hadn't
written his thank you
notes figuring that it was
all going to come back around,
but it does.
And putting out those
expressions of gratitude,
giving that gratitude really,
really makes a difference.
If you don't have a
boss, or an executive,
or a CEO who's doing
it, what do you do?
Well, guess what?
Gratitude can start anywhere.
I think another
problem we have is
that we sometimes
think that we shouldn't
be grateful to our colleagues.
I said in that survey,
we only say thank you
to our colleagues
10% of the time.
Because again, it goes back
to what we were talking about
before, that sense of ambition,
and we're all a little bit
competitive.
And if we say she
did such a good job,
does it mean I didn't
do as good a job?
It really doesn't.
We all do so much
better-- and I'm
sure your corporate
structure here
supports that-- we all do
so much better when we're
supporting each other,
and when we're collegial,
and when we recognize what
other people have done.
It just makes for a
better atmosphere.
So if you're not
getting it from the top,
you can start it anywhere.
And you can appreciate the
people who work with you.
And yeah, I'm sure there'll
be a jerk somewhere who
tries to stab you in
the back with that.
That's going to happen.
But that's not
been my experience
that that's the general
way things work.
People recognize people who are
genuinely appreciative of them,
and of what they're doing, and
who care about giving that way.
Another way that gratitude
works really interestingly
is with a spouse, a partner,
a boyfriend or a girlfriend.
I was talking about habituation
before, and the sense of people
slipping back into
the background
and becoming the baseline.
And in that survey
that we did, again, we
found that people were more
likely to say thank you
to the barista at
the coffee shop
or the guy who delivers
the mail than they were
to their own spouse or partner.
So what's up with that?
Well, I think the answer
is that you don't really
expect that much from the
barista at the coffee shop.
And if he makes you a nice
cappuccino, that's worth
a thank you.
Whereas for the person
that we are connected to,
we have pretty
high expectations.
And most of us are
really good at knowing
how our partners could
be so much better if only
they would listen to us.
And so we tend to focus on that.
We tend to be very
good at reminding them
of all of the things that
they could do better.
And the first month of
my year of gratitude,
I decided that I was
going to try to notice
my husband a little bit more.
And that I was going
to try to say thank you
to him for the things that
he probably did all the time,
but that we'd been
married a long time,
and that I'd stopped noticing.
So it started the first weekend.
And we were driving up to--
we live in New York City.
We have a house in
Connecticut also.
And we were driving
up to our house
as we do most Friday nights.
And we pulled in, and I
said, thank you for driving.
And he said, I always drive.
And I said, I know you
always drive, but you know,
I'm a lousy driver.
It's snowing.
It's miserable.
It's dark.
And I appreciate
that you got us here.
And he didn't say anything.
This was the very, very
beginning of my gratitude year,
so he didn't quite know
what I was doing yet.
And we spent the whole
weekend that way.
And I thanked him for all
sorts of little things
that he did, or told
him he looked great,
or thanked him for
fixing something.
He's a fix it kind of guy.
And he was just sort of taking
it in and kind of not sure
who he was living
with this weekend.
And then it got to Sunday night.
And we had dinner, and he said,
thank you for making dinner.
And I said, I
always make dinner.
But the vibe had changed.
All of a sudden, we
were noticing each other
and appreciating each
other in a different way.
And I was planning only to do
that for a month, may I say.
But it was such
a dramatic change
that appreciating, and being
grateful, and saying thank you
to my spouse really, really
lasted in a very dramatic way
and gave us a pretty
extraordinary year.
And on that second New Year's--
my book is written from New
Year's to New Year's.
And on that second
New Year's, I told him
that I wanted the last
chapter of the book
to be New Year's Eve.
And so he came up with all
sorts of things that we could do
to have a great New Year's.
No pressure.
It's going to be the
last chapter of the book.
Give me a perfect
New Year's Eve.
And I said, no, no, I really
just want to be at our house,
at our country house,
just with you, just a fire
and a bottle of champagne.
And again, a little
bit of pressure.
But then it got to be
a quarter of 12:00,
and we've had a wonderful night.
And again, we turn on the TV as
the previous year and the ball
is about to drop in New York.
And shamefully,
I started to cry.
And my husband said,
oh, no, I thought
I did such a good job tonight.
What's wrong?
Why are you unhappy?
And I said, no, this has
just been such a great year,
and I don't want it to end.
And he said-- I
don't actually admit
this in the book--
he said, you actually
could be nice next year too.
But it really was
so powerful to me
of how we had
reconnected that year
and how good we felt
about each other.
And again, everybody's
at different stages
in relationships and
different stages in life,
but it's sort of like a job.
If you can't find reasons
to be grateful to your job,
if you can't find one,
or two, or three things
that you can write down
right now about your job,
and put in your top drawer, and
hold on to them for those days
that you're feeling
lousy, then you probably
should leave your job.
And it's the same with a spouse.
If you can't find one reason,
or two reasons, or three reasons
to be grateful, then you're
probably with the wrong person.
But for many of us who
are in relationships,
we just forget to do that.
And the same with a job.
Take that piece of
paper out tonight.
Write down two or
three reasons why
you're excited, and grateful,
and happy that you're here.
And have them there
as that little backup,
as a reminder on those lousy
days, that you can pull it out
and go, yep, reasons
to be grateful.
And add to it as
often as you can.
And I think you'll be
surprised to discover what
a huge difference it can make.
So I'm going to
stop talking and see
if there are any questions
I can take from you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: Does anyone
have any questions?
AUDIENCE: So I think
people naturally
have different levels of
gratefulness. [INAUDIBLE]
develop to be
grateful naturally.
Did you find any patterns
between female and male,
if some cultures were more
grateful than other cultures?
Did you do any
analysis of this sort?
JANICE KAPLAN: Yeah,
that's a great question
from a data person, clearly.
We did.
And in that survey, women tend
to be more grateful than men.
And interestingly,
women are more
grateful in every
situation except at home.
And at home, men tend to be more
grateful to their significant
other than women are.
Now it may be that women
do so much more at home
that men should be
more grateful to them.
I wouldn't draw that
conclusion because I'm
sure your data may
not support it.
But I worried, at
first, that gratitude
was too much of a women
subject because it is something
that women tend to think
about more, but really not.
I think that for men,
particularly at work,
are starting to get the idea,
and starting to realize it,
and starting to realize that
there are ways that they
can make themselves happier.
Interestingly, also
in that survey,
millennials were
the least grateful.
And people actually younger than
you had probably the biggest
problems.
Maybe some of you are
younger than I think.
But people in the 18
to 24 range really
had a hard time with gratitude.
And I think for a
lot of them, it's
because they really
want to be independent.
They really want to be able
to do everything on their own,
and they can't yet.
And so we did some
focus groups, and there
would be some kids who
had just graduated college
who would say,
well, my parents are
paying for my first
apartment, and my parents
are doing this and that for me.
And I feel really guilty
that I can't do it myself,
and the guilt outweighs
the gratitude.
So I think there's
a point where it's
hard to be grateful sometimes,
in those circumstances,
because it makes you feel like
you're not as strong as you
want to be.
And I understand that.
But I think it's really
important at any age.
And I think the other thing is
that you don't want gratitude
to be something that you only
see in the rear-view mirror.
You don't want to be
looking back in 10 years
and say, why didn't
I appreciate that?
Why didn't I realize
how wonderful that was?
Why was I always so
busy running and doing
this and that that I
couldn't stop and pause
to appreciate it?
I think, sometimes, that's
a really good perspective.
When you're miserable
about something,
particularly at your
job, stop and think
how you're going to feel about
that in 10 years, in five
years, in two years.
Think how you'd feel about it
if you didn't have the job.
I often say that to
people when they're
complaining to me about
their work, their boss,
that they're working so hard.
I say, put yourself in the
mindset of if you didn't have
that job, what would you miss?
Maybe you'd miss the free food.
Maybe you'd miss the chance
to do something important.
Maybe you'd miss
your colleagues.
And if you can remember that, if
you can think about the things
that you would really
want to have again, I
think that can really
help put you back
in the mindset
that's so helpful.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I have a
really cranky grandma.
JANICE KAPLAN: You have a what?
AUDIENCE: A cranky grandmother.
She's 88, and she's
really bad at appreciating
all of the things that
she's done in her life,
and where she is now, and the
family she has around her.
Do you think there's
any tactics you
can do where you
could speak to someone
who's older to try and shift
them from being cranky?
JANICE KAPLAN: Yeah.
It's a great question,
and it's really hard.
I had it with my mom, who
was not a grateful person.
And I would tell her
what I was doing,
and she would always
have another reason.
I would say exactly that.
Look at your children.
Look at your grandchildren.
Isn't this wonderful?
And it would always
be a yes, but.
And that's hard.
And it's hard because
you see somebody
making themselves unhappy.
And I guess you can try
it, and I think you should.
And I think it's a
really kind thing
to do for the person to point
it out to them because nobody
wants to be unhappy.
Your grandmother probably
doesn't wake up every morning
and say, I think I'd
like to be unhappy today.
But she doesn't
know how to do it.
She doesn't have the tools.
And so maybe it will
be helpful to her
for you to try to
do that and for you
to try to give her that advice.
And even if it's not, it's going
to be really helpful for you
because it's going to
make you, in some ways,
more sympathetic
to her attitude.
Because you're going
to see the other side,
and you're not going to be
constantly irritated at it.
You're going to see, hey.
And you're also going to say,
I don't want to be like that.
And sometimes, a negative
role model is OK too.
And to see somebody who's-- and
I will warn you of one thing,
that once you start doing
this gratitude stuff,
you get so irritated at
people who don't get it.
You become like--
I never smoked,
but what I imagine reformed
smokers must be like.
They want to rip cigarettes
away from everybody.
You get like that.
And when people are
like your grandmother,
or I have a couple of friends
who would be always complaining
about things.
And I would just stamp my foot
and go, would you stop that?
Yes, there's this
terrible, horrible commute
that you have to have of 20
minutes, but you go to a job
that you love, and you're
in a beautiful building,
and you've had this
job for a long time.
I would just be so frustrated
by hearing complaints.
But I think that's OK.
And I think that a lot of
people start to come around also
once you start
pointing it out to them
and once you start
saying, let's just stop
and look at something from
a positive perspective.
And it makes a difference.
Anybody else?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Does your research
look at the role of technology
in gratitude and happiness?
And particularly
for social media,
for me, I feel like
there's a big resurgence
in people being
grateful and using
the hashtag on social media.
But I'm really
interested in knowing,
do you have any research
that looks into that?
And perhaps on the
other side of the coin,
how social media can make us
really unhappy and ungrateful.
JANICE KAPLAN: Well, there
were a few big articles that
came out about social
media causing--
and I forget what the phrase was
they were using-- but basically
saying that it makes
you unhappy because you
see everybody else on Facebook
posting their wonderful lives.
And you read their
wonderful lives
and say, why is my
life not that good?
And may I say I thought that
research was ridiculous.
Because we're all
grownups here, right?
We're all reading Facebook
and know that our friends
are posting positive things.
And it made me say, well,
let's use social media to make
ourselves happier then.
Because it's actually a good
thing if you think about it.
If you're posting on Facebook or
wherever you guys like to post,
you probably are putting up
the good picture on Instagram.
You're not putting up the
picture where you're crying.
You're putting up the
picture where you look happy.
picture where your arm is
around your boyfriend.
So what are you doing?
You're essentially finding
reasons to be grateful,
and you're putting it out there.
And I actually think
that's a wonderful thing.
And again, maybe
it's just a turn
on how to look at social media.
If you look at it
that way, that's
a really positive
use of social media.
And in that way, I think
that we do it naturally
because we like to put out
the best look of ourselves
to other people.
But we're also putting out
the best look of ourselves
to ourselves.
And I've actually suggested
to a lot of families
who are worried
about their kids,
and I've said, use
social media for good.
So pick a day, make Tuesday
family gratitude day.
And everybody in the family
takes a picture that day
and posts it on
Instagram of something
that they're grateful for.
And if you're embarrassed
about the #gratitude,
you don't even have to
tell everybody else.
But everybody in the
family knows that,
and it becomes a
nice little bonding,
and it becomes a way that you
can use it in a positive way.
But I think if we realize
that, in a funny way,
social media-- and
I agree with you.
All the #gratitudes can
be a little bit much,
and we don't necessarily
want to read every day why
somebody else is grateful.
Though I will tell
you that there
is one person who works
at my publishing company.
And I can't tell you his name
because I don't know his name.
I met him at a very dark
party when my book came out.
And he told me that he
texts out every morning.
And he actually had been in
AA, in Alcoholics Anonymous,
which uses gratitude a lot.
And that for the last year, he
had been texting every morning
to a bunch of
friends three reasons
why he was going to
be grateful that day.
And I said, well,
I'd love to get that.
That would be
really interesting.
And this was last May, and I put
my phone number into his phone.
And I have now, every morning
since then, gotten these.
And it's actually
kind of wonderful
because I actually
don't know who he is.
I would not know him if
he were sitting here.
And I sometimes feel like
I'm cheating, like I'm not
writing my own gratitudes.
I'm just getting his in.
But it actually starts
the day in a nice way.
And he's actually
a lovely writer.
And he doesn't write those
silly things like grateful
for coffee.
He's thoughtful in
a much deeper level.
And so I think
that there is a way
that we can share positive
feelings, positive viewpoints.
He'll send out, "I'm
grateful because it's Monday,
and I get to start the
week with a fresh slate.
And I know that I get to control
today however I want it to be,
and I get to control this
week however I want it to be.
And so I'm grateful that I
have the chance to be positive.
And I'm grateful that
I have the chance
to go forward and know
that I can do that."
And I'll go, yeah, you bet.
That's right.
So I think that we can
use social media, whatever
formats that we like, in a
very positive way that way.
MALE SPEAKER: Your question.
AUDIENCE: So first
off, thank you.
It's been fantastic.
One of the things
you talked about,
you said gratitude can
start from anywhere.
You didn't state it directly,
but are you also saying
that rather than expecting
other people to be grateful
or trying to encourage them to
be grateful, the act of being
grateful to them
yourself is a trigger
and helps them to be grateful?
Do you see that happening?
JANICE KAPLAN: I do think that's
the case, and at least in part
because you can't make
somebody else grateful, right?
You can't make your
grandmother grateful.
You can't ask somebody
to appreciate your work.
But you can stop and
be grateful yourself.
And then maybe it becomes
a little less important
what somebody else's
says to you because
the outside circumstances,
the outside events,
become a little less important.
And your gratitude
comes from within,
and your appreciation
comes from within.
And I do think it is contagious.
I do think it's very hard
to appreciate somebody else,
say thank you to somebody
else, without it coming back.
Try it at a store sometime.
If you talk about cheating.
People who don't
normally get appreciated,
a store clerk, the cashier,
give them a big smile
and say, I really appreciate it.
Thanks for your help.
And their attitude
will completely change.
And the people who you
just naturally want to get
irritated at, like the
person at the bank who's
unbelievably slow,
and you want to go,
could you count that foreign
currency any slower for me?
And instead, you say,
thanks, it's been really busy
here today, hasn't it?
And I appreciate you doing that.
And again, your
attitude changes,
and their attitude changes.
And I just think it's a
very simple, simple exchange
that you can do.
MALE SPEAKER: We'll
take one more question.
There's one-- was
one over there.
Anyone wants to ask
one more question?
AUDIENCE: In your year
that you were gracious,
did you ever have circumstances
where you found someone
who was totally unhappy in their
life and took it out on you,
and you didn't think they
deserved your gratitude?
How do you deal with that?
JANICE KAPLAN: Oh,
that's interesting.
Well, I'll tell you a story
that may answer the question.
I live in New York.
And it happened to
be a very snowy year
when I was writing that book.
As I said, I started in January.
So it was maybe March, and there
had been a horrible snowstorm.
And I'm trudging through
New York near my apartment.
And somebody was shoveling snow.
And he takes a big
shovel full of snow,
and he throws it
back right onto me.
And I, of course, responded
in the gracious way
that you would expect me
to-- with a large number
of profanities, yelled at him
to please be careful and pay
more attention to what he was
doing, and how dare he do that.
And I continued
through the storm,
storming down the street.
And then I paused, and
I thought, oh, it's
my year of gratitude.
I'm not allowed to do that.
And I literally stopped.
I literally stopped.
And I had snow all over me.
I brushed it off.
And I thought, all right,
how could I possibly
be grateful in
this circumstance?
And I knew he hadn't seen me.
And I thought, all right, I'm
grateful that this guy is out
shoveling, and I'm not.
And I'm grateful that
I live in a place
where people actually are
shoveling the sidewalk
and taking care of it.
And I'm grateful that I haven't
slipped yet on the sidewalk,
and this poor guy is
out there shoveling.
And it made me feel
so much better.
Because when you are
angry at somebody,
when you do yell at somebody,
you feel bad, right?
And so I turned around, and I
walked back down the street.
And this poor man
now looks up at me.
First, this lady
has yelled at him.
Now, she's coming back.
What's she going to do?
And I just called out, and I
said, thank you for shoveling.
I really appreciate that
you're keeping the area clear.
And he must have thought
that I was a complete loon.
Who does this?
But I turned around
and continued on,
and I felt so much better.
And I don't know how
he felt. Maybe he
was just baffled by this.
Or maybe he did say, oh, that's
nice, she said thank you.
So I think you can
always find a reason.
And I think it
goes back to what I
said before that
other people aren't
looking to be unhappy either.
And if you can help them
find a way to be happy,
and if you can find
something good that they did,
maybe it can turn things
around for both of you.
MALE SPEAKER: Please join me in
a massive thank you for Janice.
[APPLAUSE]
JANICE KAPLAN: Thank
you all for being here.
I appreciate it.